um I'm honored to bring to you today um
a warrior in the litigation Jihad in
lawfare we we know that our court
systems are being used to impose the
Sharia we know that our court systems
are being used to impose the blasphemy
laws under the Sharia um restriction of
freedom of speech under the guise of
hate speech um I have been represented
by I believe two of the foremost lawyers
in the world
in combating and fighting the Sharia uh
Robert Muse and David Yu Shi uh they
represented me in the $10 million
lawsuit filed against Me by rifa Barry's
parents that threatened her when she had
left Islam uh because I heard his
feelings I heard his feelings two years
okay and hundreds of thousands of
dollars This Is How They silence people
This Is How They bankrupt people and
they represent me pro bono
uh Robert Muse represented me along with
David Yami against the city of Dearborn
when they were running ads prosing for
Islam come to Islam why Islam and Iran
ads uh leaving Islam is your family
threatening you is there a death threat
on your head and they wouldn't run them
and we sued and Robert and David
won of course the Eds didn't run because
they filed an emergency motion as if the
judge was going to reverse herself the
same week but I have to tell you that
the week that Those ads were supposed to
go up in Dearborn it was the week that
Jessica mokdad was honor murdered uh
they're representing me in New York City
you know New York City subway system is
running anti-israel ads to end USA to
Israel well we submitted our pro-israel
ad that said in any war between the
Civilized man and the Savage you side
with the Civilized man support Israel
defeat Jihad
Those ads were rejected because Savages
hurt their
feelings yeah but these are serious
cases and I applaud Robert Muse and I
applaud David Yu sheli and the work that
they're doing for American law for
American courts the foreign law
prohibition that if I understand is here
in Michigan it's far it's far it's um HB
47 69 and
sb71 you got to get behind this ladies
and gentlemen you've got to get behind
this I mean take an active role and by
the way very very briefly when they tell
you that oh we're not going to be able
to get married and we're not going to be
able to again it's it's deception um
unlike Jewish law there is no compulsion
in Jewish law there is no compulsion in
Christian law Jewish law is for Jews
canon law is for you know cath Catholics
for Christians uh but the the Sharia is
a comprehensive legal system that a
asserts authority over non-muslims it is
different and uh frankly we need this we
need these laws and there should be
absolutely no reason why anyone would
oppose you know the fundamental
Constitution Liberties that are you know
are unalienable rights so I'd like to
bring up Robert Muse so he can better
inform you of the fight on the legal
front because it's critical thank you so
much
well thank you all for coming it's a uh
what a terrific turnout for a Sunday
afternoon that's a great I think
Testament to the uh incredible work that
Pam and Robert are doing in this area
you know I I served uh 13 years on
active duty in the Marine Corps and uh
it was my
uh and and I think it's important to
give you a little bit about of my
background you know when as a marine
officer you take an oath to support and
defend the Constitution United States
against all enemies foreign and domestic
I was an infantry officer I served in
the first Persian Gulf War and it became
pretty clear to me uh that we have
perhaps more domestic enemies to our
constitution than we did on foreign
enemies so I decided to go to law school
I went to Notre Dame I got my law degree
and I've been now fighting this these
battles for our for our constitution in
the courtrooms for the last 12
years for good or
ill for good or ill this battle for
America is occurring in the courtrooms
I'm going to cover some of that uh here
today during my presentation uh Pam
mentioned my colleague David yurami
David and I have been doing cases
together for four years some of the more
complicated complex cases in this battle
space fighting Sharia and we decided
this past January to uh join forces and
launch the American Freedom Law Center
and and to enter into this battle space
and to bring in expertise that I don't
think exists anywhere else and we've had
some some incredible success uh during
our our short time and over the years
that he and I have been working together
and I want to cover some of those cases
with you here today because unless you
hear these facts you'll think that it
never took place here in America but I
can guarantee you that we have domestic
enemies to our Constitution and those
battles are raging every single day what
I want to talk about today it describes
as civilization Jihad a threat to life
and
Liberty because in Civilization Jihad
under Sharia we don't have a rep there's
no Republican form of government there's
no freedom of speech there's no free
exercise of religion there's no due
process there's no equal
protection in fact as we've been hearing
women are chatt under
Sharia you know I'm a I'm a father of 12
children as I like to say uh all of them
are boys except for
10 so blessed are you among women in my
house and when women are cheated treated
like chattle that affects me in a very
personal
way you know I'm I'm proud to say even
though we've launched in uh in January
already this left-wing British uh
organization they did a an International
report and they've already identified
the American Freedom Law Center
highlighting it as one of the top
us-based organizations that campaign
against civilization jih hard you're
damn
straight and they also identified my
colleague David yurami is as has one of
the top 12 threats to the civilization
Jihad and they said he's arguably more
than anyone to fight civilization Jihad
you know the New York Times this past
summer did a full page story on him
front page above the fold I described
him as the man uh The Man Behind the
anti-sharia movement and he is and I'm
very proud to have him as my
colleague no this civilization Jihad it
certainly has a kinetic oppon kinetic
component as we saw on September 11th
you know it's it's amazing to me when I
when I talk to so many groups and they
say well what's the concern you know
there's the over right didn't we just
hear from our Administration that
there's no longer a you know war and
Terror I mean what does it take you know
these Sharia adherence to fly planes
into our buildings and kill 3,000
innocent Americans before America wake
up but there's another another form
stealth Jihad using the term that Robert
Spencer has uh has coined that is as
equally as pernicious as equally as
harmful and it's occurring and I see it
more so in the in the courtrooms and in
the cases that I'm dealing with and I'm
going to run through some of these but I
want to cover this thing one real quick
a study on us mosques this was a study
that was that was co-authored by my
colleague David yurami it was published
in perhaps one of the most reputable
terrorism peer review journals
perspectives on terrorism and they did a
study of us
mosques and this is what the conclusion
was 80% of us M provide their
worshippers with jih hard style
literature promoting the use of violence
against
non-believers this is a legitimate
peer-reviewed study this threat to our
freedoms is a real
threat it
exists and when I use the term
civilization
Jihad it's not even my term that's their
term that's the term that was coined by
the Muslim Brotherhood this is what they
said in explanatory
memorandum on the general strategic goal
for the group this document that is
quoted here was actually submitted as
evidence by the Department of Justice in
the largest terrorism financing trial
that's ever been held in the United
States the Holy Land uh financing the
Holy Land uh Foundation trial and this
is what this document says the process
of settlement is a civilization Jihadi
process the Muslim Brotherhood must
understand their work in America is a
kind of grand Jihad and eliminating and
destroying the western civilization from
within and sabotaging its miserable
house by their hand and the hands of the
Believers so that it is eliminated and
God's religion is made Victorious over
all other
religions those are their
words and as a footnote one of the
unindicted co-conspirators in this trial
was
care and when care filed a motion to get
their name removed from the pleadings
the motion was denied through every
level of the courts because it was
sufficient evidence presented at trial
that they should have been named as an
unindicted co-conspirator now why they
weren't indicted co-conspirator we'll
have to leave that question to ask that
question to the Department of Justice
Civilization Jihad is their words it's
not something that Robert Spencer wrote
in a book or Pam gella put on her blog
this is what the Muslim Brotherhood is
saying we all know what our apologist
and chief has been saying and what he
said in
2009 he wants to hide the fact that we
have a real threat it's threatening us
today it's threatening us both through
violent Jihad and through more
stealthier forms stealth Jihad or
civilization
Jihad let me tell you about some of the
cases the case that David wood was
telling you about I had the uh the
privilege of being the attorney that
represented him in that in that first
criminal
trial David went to the Arab festival
with three other Christian missionaries
to peacefully preach the gospel on the
city
streets and as he
indicated they went there in peace and
they left in handcuffs they spent a
night in jail
jail
thankfully thankfully they had videotape
and video cameras where they could
capture what actually took place and I'm
going to show you a 4minute clip of the
of live video of what transpired on that
night during the Arab Festival in
2010 can I can I eat this pH Yeah
question what's
up what's the
problem I have no problem is that why I
I have no problem with Muslims why are
you making all those videos
why you trying to make us look B I'm not
trying to make you guys look B the man
on the right in the red
shirt when we made the video last year
we made it explicitly clear that it was
the security we had an issue with not
everyone at the festival security then
we put up a video afterwards saying we
want to make this perfectly clear we
don't have any issue with the people
there we have no issue with the people
at Boots we only have issues with people
at security so I I got no issue with you
guys but you didn't say that in the
videos I was just saying the Islamic
people as a community are just all dead
and all my mom is Muslim my dad is
Muslim my sister is Muslim all my
cousins are Muslim I love Muslim I got
no problem with the Muslim
Community it was the security guards
here that made the
video so you came here looking for
trouble with the security guards w why
you decided making all these videos
that's a good question we came here
yesterday or last year and we saw a
pamphlet that we had a question about so
we went to the booth who gave us the
pamphlet and we said hey can we ask you
a question about this and they they said
they said yeah they said they said yeah
you can ask a question
everything I don't understand I didn't
see you at like the Spirit Festival here
another year in a row I just happened to
be here last year my first time why why
you here again we want to see if it's
going better this year we wanted to see
if it's better this year than it was
last year are you sure about that I'm
pretty sure it's all the way I think
you're looking for more trouble we're
not looking for trouble we want to see
things are better and generally things
have been better security hasn't been
hitting US security hasn't been
assaulting us so things are better I'm
glad about that and we're talking right
now and no one's stopping us from
talking so I'm glad about these things
this is the very reason I'm here to make
sure you and I can talk so you here to
preach I would like to preach we haven't
even gotten to that point yet so preach
to me then preach to you I would love to
preach to you why is Christianity better
than Islam because Jesus Christ did not
claim to be just a prophet he said he
was here to receive worship he did
receive worship he forgave people sins
he miraculously healed people he died on
the cross and rose from the dead these
truths have changed my life have
absolutely changed my life and and I
find it so important to let people know
about these things that I will tell
anyone and everyone who listen soad you
as the question Allah is like that
either why is there more one B why is
Allah makes Jesus better than Allah Who
who okay I got a bunch of you guys who
asking questions question for you so did
like four of these guys I want I want a
man a man a human when was Jesus decided
God what when was Jesus decided as a God
that's an excellent question 325 years
after the Roman ccil declared him as no
people are worshiping Jesus as God less
than a decade after his death that's not
how could Jesus be a god God if he came
like any of us came out out of a woman
he came like any other man comes out of
a woman yeah so in the Old Testament we
see a prophecy saying that a child will
be born to you and he will be the Mighty
God so in the Old Testament it actually
says the Mighty God will be born as a
child to you and in actuality it can't
just be like a half God it actually says
the Everlasting father avad will be born
to you so this is a this is a prophecy
we knew what happened right but how does
God die you said after his death he was
be God that's an excellent question what
we find in the New Testament is that in
order in order for for God to take our
sins away from us he can't just wave
them away if God were just to wave away
sins he wouldn't be a just God so he
takes our sins upon himself he says all
right I can't just wave these sins away
that wouldn't make me a just God I'm
going to pay those sins for you that's
how much he loves us and so he comes
into the world as a man and he takes our
sins for us he does it all voluntarily
he doesn't have to do any of this have
you met Jesus yourself say again not
that these are great questions guys I'm
loving this anyone else have a question
yeah uh where where in the Bible says
can you find the Bible where it says uh
when Jesus says I am God worship me well
in the Bible when people I'll give you
$100 in any Bible there's 80 of them if
you find
meity there's 80 Bibles but there's only
one one let
me okay
EXC where the microphone from
are you legally allowed to take this the
mic are you legally allowed to go
[Music]
mic that microphone that Nabil keshi had
didn't amplify sound it was simply for
the video recorder so that conversation
was normal voice conversation on a on a
city street that is quintessential First
Amendment protected activity I mean in
fact that was about as peaceful as as
one of the witnesses testified during
the trial it was almost like a classroom
session ni was taking peaceful questions
from these Muslims who had very good qu
very good questions and he had very good
answers and what was his crime breach of
Peace again I had the privilege of
representing all four in the criminal
trial in Dearborn and after a weak trial
that video is what I showed in my
closing argument and after I showed that
video I turned to the jury and I said
did what you just witnessed there what
you just saw did that happened in a city
street in the United States of
America thankfully they were all
acquitted in David Yami and I we turned
around we drafted a 96-page civil rights
lawsuit we sued the mayor we sued the
city of darborn we sued 17 police
officers we sued the chief of police and
we sued two a festival workers
and that litigation is ongoing I like
our
chances here's a case many of you may
not know that much about in fact this is
a case that where David and I started
working together back in
2008 how many of you out here realize
that you are the primary shareholder of
AIG the federal government owns 92
excuse yes the federal government owns
92% of AIG through taxpayer dollars AIG
also Happ to be the world leader in
Sharia compliant
financing and I'll tell you a little bit
about Sharia compliant financing but
first with AIG when they when things
were going arai in the economic uh in
our economy back in 2008 the feds gave
AIG $85 billion in
loans shortly after that we passed the
emergency economic stabilization act a
congressional funding statute where we
then gave him $40 billion which replaced
some of that 85 billion and then that
following April we gave him another 30
billion the first 40 billion came in
November around December AIG announced
to the to its shareholders through a
press release from its New York office
that it was now uh opening up its Sharia
compliant businesses in the United
States at the same time the Department
of Justice was having an Islamic Finance
101 seminar for all its policy holders
back in Washington DC alling all the
benefits of sharia compliant financing
under Sharia compliant financing they
can only invest in things that are are
Sharia adherent that promote Islam in
fact AIG meaning you the federal
taxpayers hires a Sharia advisory aboard
which is made up of these imams who make
determinations of how the money should
be uh should be invested a certain
percentage of that vest investment the
prophets has to come off as a zakat a
religious tax and those religious tax
can only go to fund
pro-islamic uh charitable organizations
it has to be purified organizations such
as the Holy Land Foundation many of
these organizations promote Hezbollah
and Hamas so you as Federal taxpayers
have given $70 billion in tax money to
prop up and to own AIG and now you have
the Sovereign engaged in not only a
religious practice which violates The
Establishment Clause but a religious
practice that has National Security
concerns over a year worth of litigation
and Discovery in the first once we filed
this lawsuit Department of Justice
immediately filed a motion dismiss
and we defeated that in fact the judge's
ruling was
phenomenal it was a very courageous
ruling so we had a a year to conduct
Discovery and to prove our case and we
did in fact we showed at a minimum $153
million of federal tax money going
directly to those
businesses surprisingly the federal
judge who ruled not favor the first time
around it was almost like a different
judge had written the opinion he
actually said in his opinion 153 million
out of 70 billion well that's Dom
Minimus Dom Minimus you imagine $153
million going to a Catholic
school I just argued this case before
the US court of appeals for the six
circuit last Friday we drew a fairly
hostile judge in fact one of the uh one
of the judges said well isn't just this
is just like a a public school uh
serving fish on Fridays for the
Catholics it's nothing like that in fact
the the Department of Justice attorney
who argued against me the other side
kept referring it to as sharayah law
well we got about a year before a
decision will come down in that case and
I can tell you one thing uh after
deposing some of the top level treasury
officials who are responsible for this
entire bail out of AIG the federal
government has no clue where their money
went no
clue and one of the problems here is AIG
uses what's called Consolidated
financing meaning all the money goes
into one pool and it's all comingled and
yet there's no restrictions on any of
your taxpayer money going to pay the
salaries of these IMS who by the way
some of them are pretty bad actors one
of them his uh his dad is is uh is
fairly notorious as being someone who's
called for for a violent Jihad against
the West well he's on the taxpayers
payroll working for AIG among these
other
imams I guarantee you that zakat money
is not going to go to the American
Freedom Law Center and help support any
of the work that David Ur and shami and
I are
doing but you as taxpayers now own 92%
of AI IG and you're funding all this
with your money $70 billion
worth here's a case that really bothers
me personally Jesse nto he was a
marine a marine did two combat tours in
Vietnam a retired Marine Gunnery
sergant he retired uh Sometime Late in
uh in 1980 he then began working at
Marine Corps base camp leun in North
Carolina as a civilian employee I did
two two tours uh with campon spend six
years of my life living down there gto's
oldest son happened to be on the USS
coold as a
sailor he was one of the one of the
sailors that was killed during the
terrorist bombing of the USS
coal obviously as a a father he grieved
over the loss of his
son one of the ways that he expressed
and
mourned if you look at his license plate
His official North Carolina license
plate is USS Cole
he had those decals we died they
rejoiced No Quarter for Islamic
terrorists Marine Corp base camp Lun
banned his vehicle from coming on the
base because of those decals they had
gotten a
complaint the Marine Corps installation
banned them they told the guny you
either remove those decals or you scrape
off your base decal
which is what allows him to go on the
military installations he said sir I'm
not going to remove those
decals so he went out there with the
hand scraper and he scraped off the
decals and they issued an order to him
that he wasn't allowed to bring that
vehicle on any military or federal
installation so he couldn't bring his
vehicle back on base where he worked
where he was a retired Marine had access
to all the uh of the health care and
everything
else he couldn't go visit his son's
grave mark at Arlington National
Cemetery in that
vehicle couldn't go to down to Virginia
to the the Naval Base where the coal
Memorial
is because those
decals follow the federal civil civil
rights law on behalf of GTO and the US
District Court for the eastern district
of North Carolina and the judge ruled in
our
favor you ordered the uh the base to
allow him back on the vehicle I got to
tell you that was one of the happiest
calls I ever made to to gunto when I
when I got the word when he got the
electronic notice that the judge ruled
against the uh the camp leun held it it
was Viewpoint discrimination when I
called gunny I could I could tell he was
uh he was teared up and he was crying on
the other end of the phone this is a a
combat Marine it meant so much to him
that picture there is him going back on
base with his vehicle I said gny get
your vehicle bring it in front of the
camp Jun sign takes some pictures and
send it to me and he
did here's one of the cases uh Pam gella
Robert Spencer and afdi the American
Freedom Defense Initiative uh some of
our David and my favorite clients
because as you know Pam she's always
soft spoken and never want to want to
cause any
[Laughter]
controversy love representing Pam this
is she mentioned this one already she
was she wanted to run this advertisement
on the Detroit buses
and they told her she couldn't they
wouldn't give her a reason why they just
told her she couldn't it was okay though
for them to run this
advertisement don't believe in God so
the atheist advertisement is okay but
the one addressing Islam is not
okay and in fact even this atheist
advertisement was vandalized they had
vehicles that were being that were being
literally harm physically damaged and
yet they just kept putting it back up
and they had no problem with
it well our federal judge here in
Detroit ruled in our favor once again
told
them told them they had to put the ads
up the uh the Detroit uh bus agency has
still refused to do that and they've
appealed up the cases out pending before
the US court of appeals for the six
circuit but we uh we like our chances
right now we have an injunction that the
judge won't enforce but we still want
and I I fully expect to win on appeal in
the in the six
circuit same thing happened in in the
afdi versus Mt TA in New York although
there was a couple of other Frolic and
detours in between down in Miami and and
one other stop in New York where uh just
the threat of suing them where they
backed down they allowed the ads to run
but here the afdi excuse me the MTA dug
in their heels this was the
advertisement that pan wanted to run as
she
indicated the MTA accepted these
anti-israel advertisements one from a
Palestinian Group which essentially said
look if you're on the side of Palestine
in this battle this Palestinian Israeli
conflict then you're on the side of
justice and you're on the side of peace
so if you're on the side of Justice
you're on the side of Peace what's on
the other side right it must be inj
unjust it must be violent well when Pam
wanted to run this
advertisement the MTA told him that it
was prohibited because it was demeaning
speech apparently it's demeaning to call
those who engage in violent Jihad
against innocent Israelis Savages and
obviously that line is from an an Ran's
book as well ATL shrugs well David and I
we had a 4-Hour Hearing in a federal
court in uh downtown Manhattan on uh on
April 3rd and uh after that hearing um
I'm pretty convinced even though we had
a pretty hardcore liberal judge he's
going to rule in our favor in fact when
you have a judge at the end uh turn to
your opposing Council and say how much
time do you think you're going to need
to appeal my
ruling you have a good idea where you're
going to
stand you know as mentioned American
laws for American courts that model
legislation was drafted by my colleague
David yurami and anytime this is brought
up in fact it's been passed in three
states and it's pending in in dozens of
uh dozens of other
states and anytime that American laws
for American courts shows up in the
media or it shows up in in any of these
legislative Halls immediately you have
care and the other groups going out
there claiming that it's you know
islamophobia it's a it's attack on Islam
and nothing can be further and let me
take give you a little bit of of facts
because I know the uh K and these other
organizations don't like to deal with
facts American laws for American courts
was was modeled off of federal
legislation which was re recently passed
there was this Phenom going on called
Lial uh Lial tourism where in foreign
countries they certainly don't many you
know most countries don't have the First
Amendment protections like we have so
when people write books like Robert
Spencer or or Pam Geller and that are
expressing opinions that people don't
like and some of these foreign countries
they get sued they get sued for Lial and
they get sued for defamation
and what was happening is they would
take these foreign
judgments bring them into US courts and
enforce them under these comedy
principles not comedy
comitee and so the federal government
finally woke up and they passed
legislation saying that if any foreign
law or foreign judgment if it was going
to be enforced in our courts would
violate our fundamental right to freedom
of speech as protected by the First
Amendment it's n and void and it cannot
be
used what David yurami has done is
essentially take that model legislation
and expand it not so that it it's just
the first amendment but if you have a
foreign law or a foreign judgment that
wants to be enforced in our state courts
that not only violates our First
Amendment right to freedom of speech but
violates our right to free exercise of
religion that violates equal protection
that violates due PR proc it can't be
enforced that is all the law does it
doesn't even mention Sharia but as an ex
one example in New Jersey there was a a
wife I believe was trying to get a
temporary restraining order from a
husband who was brutally treating her
very brutally I don't even want to go
into the details of what it was when he
went to the trial court level he his
argument to the judge was look I'm a
Muslim this is part of my religion this
is part of sharia my wife is my property
and the judge ruled in his
favor thankfully the case was appealed
to the appella court and was
reversed the center for security policy
whom we work with very closely Frank
Gaffney some of you probably know about
the the tremendous work that they
they're doing they have a whole website
with all the cases they did a survey of
how these the pernicious influence of
foreign laws is having an effect on our
on our Constitution and our laws and all
the American laws from American courts
does is what it says is that here in the
United States American law applies not
Sharia not any other foreign law but
American laws in the primary law the
supreme law of our land is the United
States
[Applause]
Constitution as you can see and and I'm
I'm hope I've I've been able to convey
to you today that this threat this
civilization
Jihad is a real threat it's a real
threat not only to our physical safety
as we saw in 9/11 but also to our way of
life to our constitutional
freedoms I'm very proud to be part of
these these seminars that Pam and Robert
have been putting on because I think
they've done more than any two people
that I've seen to inform Americans about
this
threat and and just to wrap it up I'd
like to point out the center for
security policy and and Frank Gaffney
has put put together this this educ
ation series on the Muslim Brotherhood
and it's a video series that's available
to you online you can go to our website
and you can see the first increment of
that but it's a it's critically
important that we become aware of what
these threats are and I applaud you as
well for spending your Sunday afternoon
to listen to us to hopefully become more
better educated about these issues and
to pass it on thank you again for your
time